[Music]
and i'm going to
take you away from your comfort zone or
from your familiar surroundings for a
little while
um i'm going to talk about a
time that i spend every year if i can uh
when i leave
arizona where i live and travel on the
other side of the world to the
foothills of the himalayas to teach
tibetan monks
cosmology and i'm going to give you a
little travelogue about that and give
you a flavor for what that's like
east meets west monk gravity is the
actual title
so let's get started when you land in
new delhi
and you're in this amazing sea of people
16 million strong wandering around
trying to get your orientation you know
you're in another world
it's an amazing place where life is
lived on the streets there are extremes
of wealth and poverty
incredible food incredible sensory
assault almost by everything that's
around you
commerce played out on the streets large
and small
it's an amazing place modern india
the vitality of the youth because most
of india
is young under 18. and
beautiful sound sight smells you won't
get the full sensory experience in this
talk but i'll try and give you it
indirectly at least when you try and go
to the northern part of india small
rural areas you learn that driving in
india is not quite the same as driving
in the west
breakneck speed overtaking on bends
people just clearing the car as you whiz
by and
multiply that minute by five or six
hours and it's quite a
breathtaking experience it's amazing
people don't die
some do i suppose but not too many given
how they drive
and at the end of all that you're in the
himalayas here seen
shrouded in mist rice paddies in the
valleys turning into
arborial preserves and tea plantations
at the higher elevations
this is the place where the dalai lama
lives this is dharamsala small hill town
in india home to the highest altitude
cricket ground in the world it's about
seven thousand feet up
and here seen through tibetan prayer
flags is the cliff
town of dharamsala the home in exile of
the dalai lama and many tibetans
population about 50 percent tibetan 50
percent indian
um a place again of mystery and magic
all sorts of sights you see walking
around the town
many temples heavy buddhist influence of
course throughout
richly decorated a sensory assault again
from the smells of the incense
and the sounds of their music playing
out
you can get up early in the morning and
see the monks debating in the grounds of
the monasteries
their formal method of learning which i
got to utilize in my teaching of the
monks and nuns
they're gentle people they're curious
they're
very interested in science even though
it's not a big part of their formal
education
and they can be fierce at times this man
geshe lockdoor is actually the head of
the tibetan library
and works he was the dalai lama's
personal
translator and the person who traveled
with him for 20 years in the west
an erudite man and sort of head of the
program that i taught in
the monks don't take themselves too
seriously encouraging me not to take
myself too seriously as i teach them
about the universe we live in
occasionally we do a little role playing
it's always good when einstein pays a
visit which pretty much happens every
time i teach there
this is bryce johnson he is the young
environmental scientist who gave me a
call out of the blue about 10 years ago
and said how'd you like to teach the
dalai lama's monks
astronomy and cosmology and i'd never
been there i had no idea what program he
was talking about but it's not a
question you ruminate over i said yes
and then figured out how it would work
how i'd get away for three or four weeks
and
fit it into my academic life and
teaching schedule
and he's the young organizer of this
conference and series of workshops which
over
more than a decade has trained hundreds
of monks and
more late laterally nuns of the tibetan
buddhist tradition
in science of all kinds not just
astronomy and cosmology but biology
mathematics
and physics the first time i went i went
with my son paul he was 17.
it was an amazing experience for him for
both of us really
and i knew at the time that there was a
book in all of this
and so based actually on my first trip
there when it was all fresh and new
i wrote a book and it's called humble
before the void
as a backdrop to teaching science to a
religious
order which is what the buddhist monks
are we have these statistics from the
united states
indicating some lack of credibility of
modern scientific theories with the
american population
these are disconcerting numbers for any
educator about half of the american
public don't think the big bang happened
almost half don't believe in evolution
or doubt that the earth is billions of
years old
and a similar percentage don't think
that the planet is actually warming
so we have a science literacy crisis in
the united states it's maybe not as
severe in europe but it's significant
worldwide and that's an issue more
people
need to learn about science in the terms
of religion and science
fields that are occasionally seen to be
at odds with each other this quote from
his holiness the dalai lama is a
striking quote
if science proves some belief of
buddhism wrong then buddhism will have
to change
and i would challenge you to imagine how
many of the world's great religions
would be able to say this about their
relationship with evidence
and science so i had to reorganize my
course essentially i threw out all the
ways i'd been teaching before because i
knew this was an opportunity to approach
my subject fresh
and i just as an organizational tool
chose to
organize it along a wheel of life in
eight parts
and we walked through the material of
astronomy getting familiar with the
universe
we started by talking about how
scientists learn anything
how we learn about the universe and
about the fact that in the history of
astronomy in particular they've only
been a couple of phases
naked eye astronomy all the way through
the dawn of time in the beginning of
humans until 1600
and then the invention of the telescope
in a long march of several centuries of
building bigger and bigger telescopes
the next revolution in seeing the
universe is in the 20th century when
techniques of radio and x-ray and
microwaves
open up the electromagnetic spectrum
that's a factor of a trillion
in wavelength compared to the range that
the eye can see
and the most recent revolution in
physics and how to see the universe
is just a few years old it's the
detection of gravitational waves
first time in 2016 and now we can see
the universe
with gravity eyes seeing the universe
involves imagination and thought
the idea of combining things to produce
an unexpected outcome
art and science are separated in our
learning and siloed in universities and
schools and that's a shame
because the thought process that as
creative scientists and artists go
through are very similar
in this brilliant example picasso has
taken
two parts of a rusted bike and combine
them to make something
brand new and recognizable that's
brilliant that's the creative process
and scientists try at their best
to do the same thing scientists try to
imagine orbits
newton here on the left imagining a
cannonball fired from a high mountain
fast enough that the earth dropped away
at the same rate that the cannonball
fell and he's visualizing an orbit
350 years before he had the technology
to launch something into orbit
more recently astronomers and artists
here in these diagrams
and paintings are imagining other worlds
and now we know
that there are billions of habitable
worlds not just in our galaxy
but in all the galaxies beyond
the monks like to learn through debate
and debate for monks is not just a
formal sterile process
it's a dynamic very active process in
this little video we see
the debate grounds of one of the great
monasteries of southern india where
thousands of monks gather
and do competitions throughout a week to
debate
various subjects the theosophy
theology philosophy and science too
we explored space and space of course is
almost unimaginably big so we had to
make
models i talked about grains of sand as
a way of contemplating the large numbers
of the universe
and also hidden worlds because as blake
said to see the world in a grain of sand
and heaven and a wild flower each grain
of sand is a unique world
we got to grips with big numbers by
imagining how many grains of sand would
fit inside a square centimeter
and then projecting that out to a san
mandala
one of the evanescent forms of art that
tibetans
and buddhists make and then destroy
after they've made the exquisite
patterns so the way of calculating this
was a way of them
getting to terms with numbers like
hundreds of millions or even billions
of experiencing those numbers in their
gut rather than just with a calculator
or as a number
the cosmos contains inestimable numbers
too
this is a tiny thumbnail shot of the
universe
seen through almost the big bang itself
this region of space is about the head
of a pen held at arm's length a tiny
fraction of the sky yet every
fuzzy patch of light is a galaxy distant
system of stars
projecting across the sky the universe
contains a hundred billion galaxy
each of them with hundreds of billions
of stars this
is the cosmos as we had to understand it
by working our way
through larger and larger numbers to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas